we don't teach active listening we don't
teach
Executives or any employee in our
company how to make someone else feel
heard feel understood feel seen
which is where it starts and if that can
happen then all kinds of trust builds
and and all the other things start to
break away the so for example when after
the murder of George Floyd
I was astonished at the number of uh
people in a leadership position
regardless of you know mid-ranking on on
up
um
did nothing
in companies people who lead teams that
after the murder of George Floyd they
didn't talk to their teams they just did
nothing and it's not because they're bad
people it's because they didn't have the
skills they didn't know how to have an
uncomfortable or difficult conversation
and so they chose nothing which makes
things worse
and uh and and and this is just a skill
we can teach people and here's how to
have a difficult conversation you bring
your team together and say
um we need to have an uncomfortable
conversation
um about race and our company
and
um uh I'm nervous to have this
conversation
because I'm afraid that I'm I'm gonna
Bumble something
I'm afraid that I'm going to say
something that will trigger somebody
and I'm afraid I'm gonna say something
or someone will say something that that
may agitate and make this worse
but I think it's more important that we
have this conversation than we than than
my fear of doing this perfectly
and that's how you start a difficult
conversation
and it is difficult but it is necessary
and those conversations are not
happening
and again not because of bad people it's
because people are afraid and they don't
have the skills to start those
conversations and it is the
responsibility of leaders because that's
what we call you leader we call you
leader because you go first not because
you're in charge but because you go
first first to the unknown first of the
difficult first of the dangers
um and it is our responsibility as as as
uh as a corporation to empower and
educate our leaders to to do the things
that they need to do with their teams
um and of course up on high same thing
um so I think that's where it begins
there's a there's a tremendous lack of
listening in our nation so listening is
a trust building exercise right if
you've if you're in a take it down to a
personal relationship if you've been in
if you've ever had a romantic
relationship it's a loved one right
um
um making someone feel heard
doesn't mean you're wrong saying sorry
doesn't mean you're wrong it just means
you take accountability for your for
your actions and I think it is important
that we attempt to hear them make them
feel heard doesn't mean we have to agree
but they have to feel heard and you know
listening is not hearing the words
you know it's making the other person
feel that they were heard it's it's it
we don't get to decide when when hearing
has happened when listening they do and
and by the way it's not 100 successful
either you know because some people are
just hell-bent on and but that's a
minority
and so I think the exercise is sitting
down with people and say tell me tell me
what's what you're going through tell me
what you're afraid of I want to
understand because we're trying to make
everyone safe I I wanna I wanna hear
what what your thing is and let them
tell their story we have no answers
we're not there to object we're not
there to react we're not there to fix or
tell them that they're wrong women are
better than this than men and I think
that has to happen and it can happen
simultaneously